thomas bonjour alors il ya eu beaucoup
de réactions a également sur les réseaux
sociaux
oui c'était le sujet le plus discuté
hier avec le hashtag on veut les noms
hashtag on veut les noms beaucoup de
tweets qui demandait donc qui sont les
ministres en question et puis qui
souligne évidemment ce deux poids deux
mesures en prenant des exemples de fêtes
clandestines où les participants avaient
eux était verbalisé il ya par exemple eu
ce week-end une fête à aix en provence
où les plats police est intervenue alors
du côté du gouvernement le porte parole
du gouvernement gabriela talent dit
qu'il ne croit pas que des ministres
aient pu participé à des dîners
clandestins et puis de son côté marlène
schiappa explique que si les faits sont
avérés alors des sanctions doivent être
prises
écoutez malaysia pas si des ministres
des députés ont enfreint des règles il
faut utiliser des amendes et qu'ils
soient pénalisés comme n'importe quel
citoyen normal et l'exécutif prend les
choses plutôt au sérieux puisque le
ministre de l'intérieur a lui aussi
réagi avant évidemment que
l'organisateur ne se rétracte et une
enquête a été ouverte par le procureur
de paris
oui gérald darmanin affirme avoir
demandé aux préfets de vérifier
l'exactitude des faits rapportés afin
donc de lancer des poursuites une
enquête est ouverte pour les chefs de
mise en danger d'autrui et de travail
dissimulé
écoutez les propos exacts du ministre de
l'intérieur qui a publié un message sur
twitter hier à la suite du reportage de
m6 j'ai demandé au préfet de police de
paris de vérifier l'exactitude des faits
rapportés a faim s'ils sont vérifiés de
poursuivre les organisateurs et les
participants de ces dîners clandestins
alors sur twitter il ya déjà beaucoup
d'enquêteurs qui mènent leurs
investigations
surtout pour trouver les participants
potentiels il faut dire qu'on voit
circuler sur les réseaux sociaux des
publications ou les organisateurs
présumés de ces soirées clandestines ne
se cache pas vraiment alors l'avocat de
celui qui est présenté comme
l'organisateur de la soirée dans le
reportage de m6 a réagi
en expliquant qu'il s'agissait d'humour
lorsqu'il évoquait la présence de ces
ministres au dîner clandestins alors
thomas à l'étranger des responsables
politiques ont démissionné pour des
faits similaires
oui en faisant quelques recherches on
s'aperçoit en effet que des ministres
dans d'autres pays ont manqué à leur
devoir d'exemplarité avec souvent des
conséquences importantes prenons d'abord
l'exemple de ce ministre néo-zélandais
de la santé qui a démissionné en juillet
dernier car il avait avoué être allés à
la plage en famille alors que le pays
était en plein confinement plus près de
chez nous c'est en irlande le ministre
de l'agriculture qui a quitté ses
fonctions l'an passé sont hors s'être
rendu un gala de la société
parlementaire de golf un rassemblement
particulièrement mal perçu alors que la
population était contrainte de ne pas
organiser d'événement et puis il ya
cette histoire qui avait beaucoup
circulé à l'époque le monsieur
confinement du royaume-uni a lui aussi
démissionné en mai 2020 des médias
britanniques avaient rapporté à l'époque
que son amante bravaient le confinement
pour se rendre chez celui qui était
alors à la tête du conseil scientifique
trois illustrations du fait que dans
cette période particulièrement délicate
les représentants politiques doivent
être absolument exemplaire sous peine de
s'attirer les foudres de l'opinion
publique
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
explications on vous retrouve évidemment
dans la prochaine matinale merci
beaucoup